hello and welcome to
another night of chess on psychology
hope you're having a great day today on
like last week i don't feel like i'm
sitting under the sun
so my face actually shows last week
there was like
same hour but like the sun was way way
too
too cool to be true so this week we have
a little bit more freedom
sun wise but the weather is nice the cat
is happy actually today is peachy's
fourth birthday so he's becoming a big
boy
also um weight-wise i gotta
be um careful on that because yeah the
last thing i need is my cat getting
diabetes because
you know he is he is still doing fine
but yeah so today we
are looking more closely at our
beloved ewonchok i have different games
that i've prepared
but um it's we usually only get to do
one really cool game if we want to dive
a little deeper
so i'm probably just going to you know
keep my hopes
for this one game for right now
and we'll see how it goes it's a very
beautiful game it's been ivan truck
and raj above and i've also
finally managed to fix the issue between
uh leeches and my chest base thanks to
ben simon
he uh troubleshooted that for me and
yeah
so let's get going i'm um
peachy will probably join us at some
point too
right now it's just it's his birthday so
he gets to eat yeah i don't know what to
do if anybody has any suggestions on
cat diets i'm all ears
all right so let's get go ahead and get
going
um hello brian ah hi siamek
there is my peachy he's eating
he is actually eating right now
okay maybe that's a good start for diet
to um
you know hi all right let's get going
uh for those of you who might have seen
this game you probably know
how cool the um how cool it progresses
but for some of you who might be you
know
my lucky day and you haven't seen this
just yet
then i can surprise you with that this
game's
beauty um so yeah
i really like this because there was a
so
some of the games that i've been showing
in the last few weeks i want to say
maybe four or five weeks
is very directly related to just
innovations not necessarily just because
of the opening but the way that these
players
continue the game and how behind
they think is very um
very novel to a great extent
so that's one of the reasons i really
like these games and i promote these
games
um so so far we have a normal opening
uh nothing really much happening here
however
um like this can also
this um this can also turn into so many
different
lines from here like i'm assuming a lot
of you
are very familiar with openings because
this is not really a beginner level
class but just for sake of argument i'm
gonna you know just
arrow it a little bit you could easily
try to um
turn it into somewhat of a dragon style
or marxist style depending on what white
would do
um you could as black easily try to
go for d6 and potentially
keep your hands still closed between if
you want to do like a
dragon maybe you want to do like rouser
you could keep your hands closed
or you could just go for e5 and you know
make it into uh make it into a
swishnikov so
these are normal and just because
of the lack of knight f6 i can't just
play bishop g5 right away
so you can simply play c4
to this is i think it's like the the
name for it is kalashnikov
but it's a little bit um like you could
easily also
play knight c3 and wait for knight f6 so
then you can play this bishop g5 that's
another
great variant too i've done both of it
so what do you think
evan trick did do you think evan truck
played c4 or
knight c3 which one do you think he did
um sandy regarding title
well yeah that's a whole different um
thing like achieving i am is
harder than wgm but
wgm is woman grandmaster so it's
more of a i don't want to i don't know
how to say it's like a
prestige title compared to i am so
when it came to when it was my time i
was just like you know what i wanted
both so i applied for boat and i have
boat
so um yeah yeah so both of them are
definitely doable i've done c4 numerous
times personally in my games
and nice c3 is another hello kitty is
another
fully respectable line as well in this
game
evan truck simply went for knight c3
and for knight c3 the idea is as i
mentioned if knight f6 i want to do
bishop g5
and transpose it to a normal switchstick
of line
but black didn't really go for that it's
rajavov and rajabov and that if i'm not
i
i believe this was a game that was
played in olympia i'm just going to
double check that yeah yeah
it was olympiad so you know they don't
want to necessarily
um they they want to fight it's a team
event
they are i'm assuming the highest of
their board back in 2004 even so
they want to fight they don't wanna you
know just they wanna
be sneaky right peachy are you sneaky
right now
and so after knight c3 a6 was
played oh kitty where are you going
i got a cat in the computer i guess his
majesty
wants to um sit
somewhere okay your majesty you go put
your
fluff ball somewhere
no we kind of have only one square to go
with tonight so i'm not gonna um
be able to ask any critical questions on
that
but now he wants to play b4 so what
should we do
probably gonna move one of these knights
right
what do you think we should do this is a
very critical kalashnikov starting
position
so black wants to play b4 wants to start
eating my um nights it's
you know easy peasy lol what shall we do
as soon as you i think my d5 is
definitely the way to go i agree
because now i'm going to ask you what if
knight f6 was played
no knight d5s what can i do now
knight f6 next move we want to play b5
can i still go for bishop g5 i think so
yes
bishop g5 could simply be a
transposition because
now knight d5 and maybe bishop here and
you take this and they take that
or with the bishop most likely and then
you got c3 or c4
and i like that yeah i think bishop g5
is what i would have done honestly
but if knight f6 there is this very
interesting knight c4 line
yeah if b5 boom knight e3 i'm already
beginning to
relocate to knights d5 if you try to
push boom
you take over here well even perfect for
me
i'll just try to open up my rook from
this side your bishop is kind of
um limited in squares
you try to you know get it out i'll
still be
protecting my d4 square next thing you
know i'm going to get
my knight sag more active and this was
actually a game that was played
between anand and ponamariov a year
before this game
so like in 2003
that was a very beautiful game too yeah
just gonna get your pieces out and just
like
go at black well it's actually very
pretty
yeah right peachy
all right i'm gonna go back to the main
line and the cat
really really has no peace he really
wants to
sit his fluff ball somewhere
okay well i can't stop him um
so yeah that was another i think that's
one of the things
that you know if you didn't play a6
right away if you did this knight f6
then i would have to do bishop g5 and
then
it would transpose but um
delaying knight f6 and starting with b5
you've already pushed me aside so
now if you played knight f6 i do really
like the slide c4
i don't have to transpose i can use your
mistake play this knight c4
want to bring it to e3 faster i like it
i would definitely try it in my game i
actually never experienced this nobody
has ever played
well no no real game not
not just bullets not like not no
tournament game has been like this for
me so
i look forward to that now if b5 as in
the game happened
uh evan truck went 95 97 now what do you
think we should do here this is a very
interesting position
it's very strange looking this 97 i
thought the other knight could come to
e7
um and then yeah we could start
considering c4 and stuff like that we'll
look into that
in a shortly as well what do you think
about this knight e7 though
well you guys think about that i'm gonna
increase the light over here
and also um mention
my my um kind of like
like most um hilarious
story that i have from ivan chuk
this i was not there personally but i
watched the videos and
i was just i think i i believe i
saw evanchok in person uh briefly
in qatar in 2015
uh qatar masters it was a really great
tournament for me i was like literally
i was like i think either the last
player
rated or like one before last so you can
imagine
how um it was a challenge for me to
win any games i won i want actually
three games that was a
very pleasant experience for me but
um besides the limited number of wins
i um i remember like that the year after
that
when there was like the rapid and blitz
and evanchuk
um one medal he like he was playing
checkers or something and it's like on
videotape
and when he went like they were calling
his name to go on the stage and get his
prize and the pictures and everything
he was still thinking about it and like
he was up there with magnus and he was
like
not having he wasn't really paying
attention to someone he was just
calculating and he was like doing hand
gestures it was really funny
that's kind of my fondest memory if it's
definitely
worth tracking that down if you haven't
seen it
and i have a weird
cat grooming situation all right so i
see some of you are suggesting
ooh knight b5 spicy some of you are
suggesting c4
i think those two are nobody has
suggested the move that was played in
the game
so i might give you another minute
i'll tell you i'll tell you what let's
let's first take a look at this maybe it
will inspire you
this night movement limits my night's
choices now my knight can't really move
backwards anymore
and i'm kind of committed to this idea
with c4
so so now c4 9 takes d5
take back knight d4 and now i get to eat
over there you see you take back
i'm attacking it with two pieces you're
only defending with one
i get like an extra pawn but black is
still has
a lot of great activity so this is
completely doable
on another note um if knight
f6 was played
we could this is we could simply play
the c4 or
if i want to be kind of boring i mean or
safe i could simply play it as bishop g5
and make you face the music of
svechnikov
instead of um like those weird lines so
let's say we did this bishop g5
and you know but now bishop moves like
take it over here you take it over there
c3 or c4 and we're back to the main line
and so after instead of bishop g5
c4 now what do you think should happen
here
black's probably not gonna you know take
over here because if i take it over here
then just say takes b5 attacking this
side attacking that pawn
gives my thought of advantage oh thank
you the last one
iq um
now if not take over here then let's say
maybe you want to play b4 to push my
knight away i'll take there over there
i'll save the knights i'm defending over
here and attacking potentially
i like this i think this would have been
an interesting game as well
this was actually a game that happened
few years
after this game between topolof and
rajabov
oh great we got some swiss nickel
players here
and um yeah it's it's very
equalized and i no no maybe not equal
it's not the right word it's very
both players have great ideas
so i don't want to say equalized maybe
equal chance yeah i want to see that's
what i want to say both players have
it's not an equalized position but both
players have great
chances equal chances of fighting so
i like that now like white's trying to
short castle black is trying to
be cute with bishop b7
and uh finally we got this cool stuff
happening and
hey i'm not complaining this is a very
cool game this was a game again between
apollophone and java feel free to check
that out
uh it's not the purpose of today's
because there is no advantage in this
game but right now i mean i feel like
this is one of those type of games
if you make you make like one mistake
and you are like bye bye so it's very
very challenging would i prefer to be
white or black
here you know i love my queen i'm gonna
go with white i like living on the edge
yeah no this is i like that all right
so let's go back to our game with that
weird 97 move
now because this knight moved away i
have this potential for knight b4
do we care about knight b4 should we
retreat
remember if the other knights jumped to
e7 we wanted to play c4 because we can't
really play this knight before now
what about the weird knight jumping to
e7
oh
and especially if you do bishop b5 well
this kind of
didn't really allow you to do that
necessarily because
it wasn't like an exact switchnikov it's
kind of transposed from like a
um kalashnikov and it's not
exactly you know especially glove is
with that knight on cc
on f6 and we don't really have that here
so it can get quite tricky
what do we think now any
votes for knight going to east b4
i wish i could do a poll right now
honestly
it is 5 a.m there where are you at
maybe you're on well yeah kind of ten
and a half hours
what makes sense getting the bishop
out
i kind of like that idea but we don't so
the strategy behind this game a lot of
whoops my books are falling from up
there
whoops just a second this strategy
a lot of strategy in this game is
very related to um
that d5 square so it's a lot of it is
about d5 squared do i have control over
it
if i don't have enough control then i
should increase my control
so you don't it's it's like a constant
fight on that d5 and d4 squared these
two
are very crucial squares on
this game so it's very important for us
to you know look for that so
we don't want to lose that we i wish we
can you know we could just magically
bring this knight closer
so but we can't do that right away uh if
we were to play anything besides knight
b4
knight b4 is the good idea if we were to
play something like c4
unfortunately take take take take
we lose that and even if you try to you
know be cute and take it to the queen
that doesn't really work because there's
a bishop music there's a knight of six
whoops and like the the control over
um d5 square black gains a lot of
control over d5 square and
you know we lose complete control we
don't want that we don't want to lose
control so when knight
e7 i don't want to give you the chance
to take it because i'm not
ready to take it back with the knights
at least not legally
so because i can't make that legal
because i can't play
illegal chess it feels weird to say oh
well because we can't do that
then we gotta you know retreat
um yeah if you can retreat oops
ah if you can retreat your knight i can
retweet my knight too
and yes so white blacks knight is kind
of just like hang on a7
trying to look out for the d5 square so
is my knight
i really really this um this knight on d
b4 um is very good it has such a great
um
control over the d5 square and it's kind
of just
ready for the other knight like if my
other knight if i could just do like a
c3 and get this knight
rolling that would be great why not to
e3 that's a great question the problem
is that it closes this bishop so now if
knight f6
and then d5 i can't really do anything
with my bishop over here
but when i play knight b4 let's say if
you were to play like knight f6
then it's not like necessarily i want to
play bishop out here but it
my bishop is open so i have some chances
uh
also also uh with the knight being on b4
i can't have like a you know
little eye on your pawns now if you play
like whoops again knight f6 i could go
for c4
you try and take over here i'll take
there
because my game as white is very much
focused on the queen side and center
rather than
the king side your game for black is
very much in like kingside center so
i don't want to do that not even if you
like
try to not take maybe what else can you
do
maybe maybe maybe no it kind of
got like i don't know d5 just feels
weird i can simply take it
and it's like no this is way too
fun for nope that ain't gonna happen
nobody is not
gonna play something like this unless um
it's home prepared you can't nope uh
nope
don't play d5 oh thank you keshav
yeah it's his birthday he's being a big
baby
um knight e4 also possible but we take
and if again
a5 you know again i get to
um poke around with my knight so that's
why
i really really do like this getting the
chance
to that knight on b4 is great because it
gives me the chance to
move it around and like get it to a6 or
whatever
and as is good this knight on b4 would
be much more useful than on e3
um now let's see with knight on b4
yeah exactly this knight here makes
looks kind of funny at this point
so let's say bishop goes to d7 maybe i
want to start pushing and my pawn is
defended
i don't necessarily like bishop d7 it
feels too
empty what opening led to this oh that's
a good question
so um this happened from kalashnikov
like it started um being able to almost
transpose to
uh sveshnikov but black didn't really
want that
and white got a chance to um
activate the knights faster so it's
definitely sicilian
and it's not kalash it's not swishnikov
yet but it's definitely kalashnikov
there was a lot of chances that it could
transpose but
it didn't so good for us
so c4 now what
ah your cat's birthday was april 1st
your dish babies are it's april 7. and
my birthday is next thursday
sure we got a lot of april's here don't
we
he's being so all right
now what do you think what can do now
let me also ask you
what do you think about taking over here
do you think this works because if it
does it's a free pond we shouldn't say
no to free pawns
free palms are delicious
exactly yep thank you for bringing that
josh
yeah that's what i was what i'm kind of
i'm trying to get you
the viewers to give me an answer what do
you think would happen if queen d6 what
do you think black should do
what is my cat's breed i believe he's a
tabby
right peachy i think i'm pretty sure
he's a tabby
i was actually telling that to my mom
last night because she had similar
question
no knight c6 the problem is that the
knight can take it back
and now i'm attacking your queen so if
you take it over here i'll take it over
there you take it
back i'll still it's you know it's still
three pieces
two three pieces you didn't really win
anything
if anything you also gave up a pawn so
not knight c6 but you're correct on
moving this knight so where do you think
this knight should do
no no knight f5 you also lose on this
guy careful if you go knight f5 just
queen takes e5 it's the check
careful careful guys nope knight g6 is
the best yeah you guys found it yep
and it's attacking the queen and also
the knight so the queen got to come back
to defend this night
now black has upper hand by um
i mean the tempo wise knight f6 not
attacking another one
and you have you get into a very
defensive position and now another
attack
black's momentum and peace activity and
all those
are much better than white at least at
the moment
so let us go back
all right so now we don't want to take
on d6 we said no to that because of
knight g6 and black gets momentum
so we don't want to take that we were
talking about potentially liking c4 do
we still like c4
because c4 is one of those very crucial
moves that we want to do
right
yep so how do we want to do it
uh c3 here the problem with center is
that it's too
slow knight just goes to f6 you play
bishop d3 defending it then d5
black manages to break free quite uh
quite fast and we don't really want that
just
in no we we have to we have to face this
d5 so we have to do this c4 hello bram
yes we have to do c4 now if you try to
be
cute and play a5 i get to move my knight
back
however let's say you didn't play a5
let's say black tries to go maybe knight
f6
what do you think we should do now
attacking my pawn should i defend this
pawn or should i go for this pawn
so you kind of have two choices
it's not a neidorf but it is a sicilian
you had that right
it's a kalashnikov which sounds like a
weapon i'm pretty sure that's a weapon
is it let me actually check that out
kalashnikov
i'm pretty sure yep that's a rifle
so i thought they're watching all these
murder mysteries i better know my
my weapons right
no if it defended the problem is that
black takes it he gains momentum
and then he goes knight g6 is running
over here
it's not a good choice for us
we gotta take it
yeah we get a lot of past pawns
now if you take over here i'll take that
with my knight i'll put this b4 knight
to use two you know this knight worked
so hard
went boom boom bam boom
oh my god this this gives me a headache
this also looks like a weird
star yeah so
um we don't want to exactly i mean i
don't i honestly i would prefer to
pick my knight and just like attack
opponent so
yeah why not
yeah yeah if you try to buy a
kalashnikov you better be licensed
um yeah so if knight takes c4 and i
takes a6 and this kind of gets a little
too funny for us because i have like all
these pawns over here
all these pieces over here and black is
going to try to do something in
potentially
king side slash center
but i get to push my position in the
queen side
so and white does have a pretty good
advantage so not knight f6 kind of has
to
fight back in the queen side we get the
knight back and
now knight f6 now what do you think we
should do
yeah a lot of a lot of pawns are
just there
are you doing fish
no remember we want to do stuff in the
king side oh thank you thank you a
for your sweet words let's kick that guy
take back take back and that's the way
we do it
this is actually what happened in the
game now let me go just just a few moves
back and
question this decision to make knight f6
what if b4
what do you guys think about b4 kitty
you can't be sleeping on the laptop
i don't want my laptop to turn off
midstream kitty
you got a big booty move it
okay i think we're good
no he's a good cat he just likes my
laptop too much
and i have to move him again
right ugh let's move this to [ __ ]
there we go
good boy
okay he almost fell no injuries
all right good
i managed to um gently put them down
well that sounds weird gently
put him on the floor there we go uh yeah
you got to definitely move this knight
b5 is the best place to go if take
take back and this is again
one of those pretty um
ways to have an extra cool pawn
rolling around take and
this is a very gorgeous position i don't
know if i would necessarily play b6 in
my game but i really do
like this idea of being able to do
bishop e5
kicking the knight knight moves away and
i
am very um hopeful for this position it
has a clear advantage
so let's go back back back
so instead of b4 let's do this idea that
we had with
knight f6 take and what do you think
about my takes e4
yeah pj went to drink some water he has
his i had to
make a little like water fountain for
his majesty in the bathroom so
he goes there and he drinks water i
think i'm basically his
i don't feel like a cat mom i feel like
a
cat server anyways
um no careful knight d6
no no no no no queen d6 exactly
use your tactical brains everybody take
boom
tank boom now this is a gorgeous pawn
you try to be creative and i'll just
put my king in safety and i have this
very beautiful extra pawn
especially past pawn all right
so yes that's why knight takes e4
wouldn't work because we seriously are
threatening checkmates right now so you
gotta take it
take back and now um we how do you think
we should continue we should get these
bishops out definitely this knight could
be more activated it's just a matter of
how
how do you think we can achieve that
we gotta get some some stuff out
hi i kind of like bishop
d3 honestly and then you would play like
d5 when i would castle i think that's a
beautiful way to go about it we could
try the g3 and then get the bishop out
to g2 i like both of them
but unfortunately not unfortunately
another
great idea is to just get bishop e3
i want to support this pawn i want to
avoid queen b6
this is another good two
um after bishop b3 white
should be quite white should be kind of
expecting this d5 right
so now what do we do after d5 it's
getting a little
too cute so we have to be um careful
i can't read arabic because only because
it's the similar alphabet to var c but i
can't
really understand what i'm saying in
arabic maybe very few words
if it's like i don't know i can't really
speak it or understand it
i will be analyzing viewer games today
after this one
yeah let's go for b6 there we go let's
push this pawn
also i want to give you bishop b5 so
here it looks like white is doing so
well
right um but you have to be quite
careful
it's not that you're doing too well or
not it's that
um opponent always has a way
there we go rajabov has a way uh
do am i trying to play that uh over the
board games
um i'm waiting to get vaccinated first
and then i'll see how it's going
because you know i like my life i
like being vaccinated and all so yeah
f5 now if you try to attack the king the
king has a
little leeway to run so something like
um
maybe b7 at this point might not might
not be as
practical you just bring the rook if i
try bishop a6
now you just have queen d7 or
uh even like knight d6
so it can get a little tricky but let me
ask you
um b7 we have like
few choices one of them is b7 because
you know i like to push pawns
the other one can simply be bishop b5
what do you think about bishop b5 check
it's a check it's definitely worth
thinking
i'm not saying that i'm not saying which
one is better or which one we should
definitely
think about or not but i am saying that
at least that we should make candidate
moves
between b7 bishop b5 or trying to
include the queen
so these three are
some of the things that we should
definitely be doing
i agree king f7 but like which one which
one do you think we should do
we should a b7 or bishop b5 now you try
to like kick the knight and then try to
get more active position in the center
but that's perfect but compare this
position
keep this position in mind let's try to
for um
go a little bit farther now look at this
position
and now let's go look at b7 line keep
that position in mind
and then look at b7 rook b8s i gotta
defend it
now let's say you try queen d7 to avoid
any type of
cute checks now what do you think we
should do
as white queen d7 is not the only move
i'm just kind of
trying to make a point about it
what you think we should do
yeah we can do oops we can definitely
get the queen more involved we can
we can start considering this take take
take and i just castle d4 i will give
that up two and now i can consider
something with
getting my rooks a little more involved
it's definitely doable
and let's look at something besides
queen d7 let's say
d4 now i have to give my knight up
give you a check and this is still
very very gorgeous honestly
uh it's very promising for white now
let's look at another line if not d4
let's say maybe knight d6 now what
because white is the one forming an
attack but if we can't find the right
way to
form this attack then black can easily
run away with it
let me not run away but get away with it
yeah
oh it's kind of rainy out there
it's getting really dark and rainy
what do you think we should do as white
uh bishop g5 is interesting but why not
just queen e2 as we just saw i want to
go for b5 square
or give you a bishop a7 now this one oh
my god this
is um i didn't find this move personally
uh this is not the move that i found but
this is a great analysis so right now
what do you think white can do white has
dwight definitely has an advantage but
um how can we put it in good use
all right well this is a cute little
storm that we got going here
hopefully i won't have any um technical
issues
so what do you think
no no no it's not it's it's not queen uh
it's not a move with the queen
see my my bishop is under attack your
knight is under attack so if somehow i
could you know
um strategically get rid of my bishop
and i could still
eat your knives that would be kinda cool
oh yes i knew it was gonna rain but i
didn't expect it to be like
rain rain all right so i uh bishop d4 i
we still got a few more um lines to
check out in this game
so i'm gonna try and
work through it a little potentially
faster than i would
usually like so yeah bishop d4 if you
take it i'll take it over here i want to
give you bishop's c6 check
if let's say you're trying to be cute i
can give you check
you move then i move my bishop away um
i can still definitely take it over here
and no i definitely like this it's a
it's a good position
oh that's the mosquito that's been
ah i wish i had a spray or something
ah man i just found a mosquito that's
been biting me
all right back to the real life where i
am more capable of you know
not getting eaten alive by mosquitoes
now after
f5 no b7 no bishop b5
let's go for queenie too normal stuff i
want to bring my queen i want to include
my queen
queen 2 is definitely interesting
honestly from these lines that
we saw i liked um
i really liked i didn't really like the
b7 as much
but i did really like this idea with
bishop b5 check i thought this was an
interesting position
i i was quite comfortable in this
position i thought i had a strong attack
however nothing wrong with queen e2
and then i want to bring it to b5
it's like someone's showering up there
and
um now after king f7 what do you think
we should do with our king
we still got a long way to go shall we
long castle or should i try to still
push for short castle
i don't know how much you guys can hear
from this um
lovely shower that we got going on
yeah let's go let's be fearless or
something castle is great yeah
this castle um i was quite skeptical on
this
i've seen this game before so i knew
that there would be a long castle
somewhere
but i i don't really remember when i was
looking at i didn't
really remember every single move but i
knew the
the basic ideas of what was happening
so
yeah um lawn castle is okay i know right
so weird long castle is great because
now
black isn't a pickle you still got to
get your pieces out
in the game rojava played queen d7 which
is
not a very um how can i say it nicely
it's not a very uh genius move but i
like rejected i don't want to
say bad stuff uh it's not necessarily
the best
idea let's go with that yeah oh yeah
that was a lightning okay
i i don't like lightnings um
queen d7
definitely worth considering but it's
kind of
it's not exactly a good maneuver
maneuver
i can never say it right it's not
exactly a good maneuver there we go
uh the best way for queen d7 for black
to continue
is not necessarily with queen d7 but
something with g6
trying to get this bishop out now if you
try to be all
attacky with white f4 you get the bishop
you still like it's such a great fight
but
black still has a great chance with this
fight
you know it's looks scary but believe me
it's not
as scary as what happened in the game
black is actually holding on this
because black also
can i ah almost hit it
sorry um black's
doing fine that's not really a big
problem
with the position both kings are weak
both centers are open
all the pieces are active so it's kind
of hard to make that evaluation
black definitely has a great fight
so g6 would be the best way to go
black made a mistake played queen d7 now
can you tell me what's white's best
move we got few more moves to go through
um less than 10 moves before this game
is over
but white now is actually we can see
that white actually does have a pretty
cool advantage
even from now looking at it so what do
you think
okay okay i like the g4 idea how about f
how about something like f3 i kind of
like that too just kick the knight
um i like those uh g4 f3 all of those
look pretty cool
how about simply king b1 i just wanna
save my king and i wanna you know
keep it in a um
safe position and i don't wanna have to
worry about my king all the time
potential knights see tree checks
potential like attacking over here's i
don't wanna have to deal with that so
i'm going to move my king
just a little bit again black made a
mistake and played queen e6 the better
move would be to go for
g6 and i could try and activate this
bishop then we could try that g4 again
would be similar to the previous
position
but queen e6 does not make that much
sense you're not really attacking
anything
maybe you want to push pawn and attack
the bishop but that's not really the
best way to go about it either i'll just
get f3
and now what do you think white should
do
this was that this is another kind of
like critical almost critical position
it's not as scary
always play king b1 i mean it's not a
bad idea
it is perfect exactly thank you
you
okay ah hello i'm glad you're joining
our stream
yeah we're we're kind of deep in this
game between evan chuck
and raj above so we're kind of hoping to
spice it up a little bit
okay
i like you're so like i see a lot of f4s
g4s making the queen dance
the f4 is actually the best which
evancho founds too
um
yeah f4 i like it now what about
knight going to c4
if you try to play something like e4 i
can just bring the knights attack you
you move away and
i'll just you know like shift the whole
position one
rank uh one file to the other side and i
think this is pretty interesting
um how but like if you try to play
something like knight c4 still try to
keep it active now what
what do you think we can do here
should we take it should we try to move
the bishop
b7 interesting but no no b7 just kind of
helps you because if you play b7
rook b8 it kind of helps the opponent i
like this pawn here it's kind of
keeps the opponent's position under
under wraps i guess that's the right way
of saying it
no honestly taking is just good we don't
we don't really need to try and defend
the bishop
as long as you try something like rook
b8 uh my bishop is still kind of under
attack but we don't really
we're not really worried about that
because we want to open your king
g4 we want to open this game right
now if you try to play f4 or jacob was
kind of trying to
somewhat keep the king side close but
that doesn't really work either i'll
just play queen f3 and i'm still gonna
take it over here
you try the g5 now i can you know
eliminate this knight
now my bishop is safe my i kind of like
this idea would drop d6 maybe too early
because e5
could maybe fall you can't really even
take this because i'll have bishop d4
like it's so
awesome i'll just open your king for a
little bit
yeah um so now in the game rajapov
knows that like the white is much better
and now black's still trying to fight
so the idea was he played queen c6 to
try and exchange the queen should we
exchange the queens
we have we have a pretty good endgame
too if we try to exchange the queens
just should we
i agree we shouldn't we definitely can
if we want to and it's still like plus
three but we shouldn't
give this check there we go now if you
try to um you can't really take it with
the king because hello
you know whoops if you try to take it
with the queen
i can still take over here and
um now this pawn is definitely falling
next move
and then the knight can get activated
it's so cute we don't even really need
that knight just yet so
ha e6 he tried to go for king g6
now what white is like super winning all
i have to do is find the right sequence
of moves
honestly here h5 works too
but what else let us how can i try to
keep the
pressure
it's pretty good game i agree
attacking the queen
well careful because my queen is under
attack right now we don't necessarily
want to exchange that
oh thank you for your support from iran
hopefully it's not i've heard such my
dad is a doctor
working in iran so i i've heard the
horror stories of how kobet is getting
really really out of control in iran and
there is no real vaccine there too
so my parents are there so
keep them in your wishes and prayers
because it's
it's like it's past red stage it's more
like brown at this point
so the situation in iran covet wise at
least
yeah it's not it's not a good situation
honestly uh queen h3 could also work but
it's
your your your queen belongs in the f
file let's keep it there because you
can't really take it i'll give you
checkmate and literally three moves
you come here i'll take that such a cute
double check
yeah you can't really do that um
you can't really take so queen f2 if you
try to take that pawn
now i can simply save my bishop attack
your rook as well
and continue with opening your king
in the game black played rook d8 and
i think rojo was realizing that he's in
real hot waters but he's still trying
his best
so um
yeah now what do you think white can do
this is such a chill move honestly what
do you think white can do
we need to bring a little bit more
pieces but this is like super winning
honestly even if you take it over here
it should be good enough
yeah rookie one attack the queen queen
moves and you just go bishop c5 you want
to eat this night
when in doubt eat pieces it's a good
idea seriously like whenever you
are unsure about what what's happening
to your position you can't find the best
way to
um make it work
yeah go and eat some pieces ah there we
go
another check you got to move this king
and i'll take it over here
yeah it's just like you can't i mean
it's like so
so so winning yeah all right um
well that's all i had for you uh
regarding yvonne chuck today
we went a little over time uh but
i'm gonna take maybe about five a little
over five minutes break and we're gonna
do the switch to twitch
so we're gonna switch to 2h and analyze
your games so
uh please have some really cool games
ready for me
winning losing uh position whatever you
want
and you're gonna analyze your games we
are going to
um kind of start you know prioritize
subscribers
because they're subscribers and we
have benefits but yeah
uh there are twitch accounts the club
switch account sandler's chess club
on twitch we will be doing these games
on leeches
so please come over on about five
five minutes or so i just need to make
some small adjustments
and we are gonna analyze your games on
twitch
on leachates so semilicious links on
twitch
and if you're not a follower subscribers
please do so we appreciate your
following
in your subscriptions and
i'll see you in a little